My name is Conan O'Brien and no I'm not a White Walker.
So let's get that out of the way.
(audience laughs)
I'm so sick of that, I walk around San Diego,
and people are like look the undead!
Trying to stab you with shards of glass.
I know I know, crazy here as always Comic Con
is incredibly crowded isn't it amazing it is so crowded.
(audience cheers)
Here's how crowded Comic Con is, I had to wait in line for
three hours just to host this show.
(audience laughs)
(audience applause)
Just waiting
(imitates lightsaber)
Man, it is really great, it's very great, to be
at Comic Con surrounded by so many
powerful superheroes, it is yeah.
(audience cheers)
Especially on the day that that OJ Simpson
was paroled, I have to tell you.
(audience boos)
It's a feeling of safety.
Are they booing me, OJ, I don't know
what they're booing there.
They're saying juice
[Conan] Oh they're saying juice, oh good!
That's nice that's nice, anything
to make that guy feel better good job everybody.
Big announcement yesterday from
the creators of Game of Thrones, you've probably heard this,
the people behind Game of Thrones are creating a new show,
about the South winning the Civil War.
Yeah, yeah true story, yeah,
it's called the 'Trump Administration',
(audience applause)
Speaking of Game of Thrones, speaking of Game of Thrones,
during the premier of Game of Thrones, this is true,
it was in all the papers, all the sites, during the premier
of Game of Thrones fewer people were watching online porn.
(audience laughs)
That's true! Yeah, yeah, apparently for that one hour
the only thing coming was winter.
That's mainly a true story!
(audience great applause)
[Conan] Come on!
No, why did you do that again?
Why did you do it again?
And then to give me that afterwards.
He's like we did it kid, with your nipple
and my rubber we're going places!
(laughter)